pensemos un poco sobre el mercado
laboral y recuerden que en todos estos
vídeos ya sea que hablemos de rentar
unidades o de contratar a alguien
estamos tratando con modelos demasiado
simplificados y lo hacemos así para
poder aplicar algunas de estas ideas
básicas que hemos visto en esta serie de
vídeos de microeconomía pero es
importante hacer notar que estamos
haciendo una simplificación enorme y
muchas veces el contexto real es
bastante más complejo pero nos ayuda a
comprender los conceptos básicos
este es el mercado laboral para las
personas que no tienen alguna profesión
en particular o que no tienen algún
entrenamiento específico o experiencia
para ciertos trabajos el eje vertical es
la tasa del salario por hora
esencialmente es el precio del trabajo
esta pequeña brecha indica que comencé
en cero pero después salte hasta cinco
después está el 6 y luego el 7 este eje
horizontal es la cantidad de trabajo y
recuerden que esto está en términos de
millones de horas por mes nuevamente
tenemos esta pequeña brecha aquí que
indica que de cero saltamos a 20 a 20
millones de horas
21 22 23 etcétera y es importante darse
cuenta que cuando pensamos en la demanda
en este contexto del mercado laboral no
estamos hablando de consumidores
individuales
estamos hablando de empleadores en la
mayoría de los casos la demanda viene de
los consumidores individuales pero en
este caso en particular la demanda viene
de los empleadores las personas que
quieren contratar a los trabajadores y
aquí la oferta no está viniendo de las
corporaciones la oferta viene de las
personas que quieren trabajar es decir
trabajadores individuales ahora digamos
que este mercado inicia totalmente sin
regular así que tiene un precio de
equilibrio natural de un sueldo de 6
dólares por hora y una cantidad de
trabajo de 22 millones de horas por vez
pero imaginemos que el gobierno en esta
ciudad hipotética no está de acuerdo con
esto piensa en que 6 dólares
un sueldo muy bajo con el que no se
puede vivir bien ellos piensan que este
punto de aquí es muy bajo
quizás muchos de los votantes ganan este
sueldo y pues no están de acuerdo y les
dicen saben que vamos a aprobar una ley
que establezca un salario mínimo así que
esta ley indica que el salario mínimo
que puede recibir cualquier persona que
trabaje debe ser de al menos siete
dólares la hora así que ese es el precio
límite inferior en el mercado cuando
hablamos del control de la renta
mencionábamos el precio tope que da el
precio máximo de la renta y aquí tenemos
el precio mínimo para el trabajo vemos
que este límite inferior en el precio es
mayor que el límite natural por lo que
va a distorsionar el mercado nuestro
límite mínimo está por aquí arriba a los
siete dólares y qué es lo que va a
suceder si vemos la demanda
los empleadores van a decir vaya
que pagar siete dólares la hora pues
sólo podré pagar 21 millones de horas
por mes ya no las 22 que podía
permitirme antes pero en cambio si vemos
a la oferta a los trabajadores ellos van
a decir caray si me pueden pagar siete
dólares por hora pues voy a tratar de
buscar trabajar más horas
si yo trabajaba 40 horas a la semana por
seis dólares la hora si ahora me van a
pagar siete dólares la hora pues estoy
dispuesto a trabajar 45 horas a la
semana o quizás puede hacer que algún
estudiante se decida a trabajar y
estudiar o quizá una persona que está
retirada y nada más se encuentra en su
casa al ver que se está pagando 7
dólares la hora pues lo inspira a salir
de la casa y entrar a trabajar de nuevo
así que la oferta vista como horas que
las personas están dispuestas a trabajar
va a aumentar así que a siete dólares la
hora de trabajo las personas van a estar
dispuestas a
bajar 23 millones de horas por mes pero
qué va a pasar en esta situación pues
tenemos a todas estas personas que
quieren trabajar más pero solo hay
demanda para esta cantidad que es menor
así que aquí va a haber una sobreoferta
de trabajo va a haber una sobreoferta de
trabajadores que tienen trabajos para 21
millones de horas por mes pero aquí las
personas quieren trabajar 23 millones de
horas por mes así que aquí va a haber
bastantes trabajadores dispuestos a
trabajar estas horas pero que no van a
poder de hecho no se van a poder pagar
dos millones de horas por mes y
tendremos personas que buscan trabajo
pero que no lo van a poder encontrar y
nuevamente les recuerdo esto está
tremendamente simplificado porque pues
en este punto de acá con base en lo que
vimos en este modelo no se tendría
ningún desempleo y todos sabemos que aún
cuando la economía está en su máximo
esplendor y no hay alguna regulación
siempre va a haber algún
una cantidad de desempleo ya sea
personas que renuncian a su trabajo o
personas que están buscando nuevos
trabajos así que podemos ver esto como
un exceso de desempleo en este mundo
ideal de nuestro modelo en este punto
casi no habría desempleo pero ahora
tenemos más personas que están buscando
empleo ya que han aumentado el sueldo
pero se ofrecen menos trabajos ya que
los empleadores se ven forzados a pagar
más si usando este modelo nosotros
quisiéramos saber qué tanto menos hay de
empleo debido a todas estas personas que
ahora están buscando empleo basados en
estas líneas básicas de las curvas de
demanda y de oferta antes había una
demanda de 22 millones de horas de
trabajo y también era la cantidad de la
oferta de horas de trabajo que había
pero ahora sólo hay 21 millones con base
en este modelo tendremos un millón de
horas de trabajo menos y ahora si
quieren ver esto en términos de
excedente o sobrante antes del salario
mínimo el excedente total era toda esta
área de acá nuestro sobrante que se
encuentra abajo de la curva de demanda
encima de la curva de oferta y ésta
estaba dividida entre el sobrante del
consumidor y el sobrante del productor
así que entre el precio y la curva de la
oferta está el excedente del productor y
en este caso los productores de trabajo
son los trabajadores individuales así
que este es el beneficio que está por
encima del costo de oportunidad que
obtienen los trabajadores esta área de
acá y el excedente o el sobrante del
consumidor era el valor que obtenían los
empleadores por encima de la línea del
precio hasta por debajo de la curva de
demanda ahora con esta situación del
salario mínimo este es el precio
establecido aquí está la cantidad de
trabajo que se está demandando y ahora
el excedente que se está perdiendo es
esta cantidad de aquí y podemos
encontrar esta área esta base de aquí es
de un millón de horas por mes así que
será uno no voy a escribir las unidades
solamente recuerden
un millón de horas por mes por esta
altura de aquí de 5 a 7 que es de 22
dólares por hora esto por dos
multiplicado por un medio si
multiplicamos estos tendríamos todo este
rectángulo pero como es un triángulo lo
multiplicamos por un medio y esto es
igual este se cancela con este y nos
queda igual a 1 y las unidades son
dólares por hora por millones de horas
por mes lo que nos da millones de
dólares por mes así que esto es un
millón de dólares al mes
y esto es de excedente del beneficio
total que está perdido en este mercado
debido a esta regulación si es que
nosotros suponemos que ocurre en todas
las cosas de este modelo y como hablamos
en el vídeo anterior tenemos una pérdida
de peso muerto de un millón de dólares
por mes
ahora tengan en cuenta que no todos
pierden aquí ya que el sueldo mínimo
está aquí arriba para aquellas personas
que si están empleadas esas personas que
están trabajando estas primeras 21
millones de horas por mes su excedente
de producción ha aumentado ya que el
espacio entre lo que reciben y el costo
de oportunidad ha aumentado para
aquellos que tienen la suerte de tener
un trabajo ahora tienen un excedente o
un sobrante mucho mayor pero para
aquellos empleadores que se encuentran
aquí en esta parte de la curva de
demanda el excedente que ellos tienen
por estar empleando a esos trabajadores
pues ahora tienen un excedente mucho
menor un excedente de consumidor menor o
el excedente del empleador así que para
las primeras 21 millones de horas de
trabajo se ha redistribuido el pastel
entre los empleadores y los empleados
pero debido a que se está elevando el
salario mínimo se está reduciendo la
demanda en general y por lo tanto se
está perdiendo trabajo aquí